[__] yeah do you feel it ah yes I love
yes oh good
[__] God shut up hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to
another game about love now you know me
I'm a creature of love inside my heart
burns yearning love for the power of a
thousand suns I love love and I love to
love love and I love when I get love and
when you get love you know that you love
love lover than love so together we're
gonna go on an amazing dating experience
with your ye foo which everyone knows is
Japanese for love of your life and so
when we go on this experience together
you know that these these bad hands
right here they're gonna find love
they're gonna feel love Oh
now with this game I need you to pay
attention very closely because this is a
story of love and I'm gonna be exploring
it for you but don't be afraid to put
yourself in my body while we play this
together there's more than enough ye
food go around for everybody it doesn't
just have to be about me oh no it can be
about us all so please close your eyes
open your hearts you're deep in your
loins for the luscious feeling of love
all right let's do this
may not like overwatch may but may in
the uncanny valley may hi hello hey it's
me
bae mat these TV programs are so boring
you say
oh i would like to play something why
are you looking over there look alright
[Music]
okay Oh Mae listen I would love whoa
whoa hey come play with me okay whoa
beat Mae three times to unlock the next
stage all right
Oh Mae I love you are you not gonna go
first you're gonna let me go first
I can't believe it go first I will I'm
gonna beat you though never mind
you're bound well I mean you don't have
to be so rude about it all right here we
go nope okay all right then go pretend
that didn't happen all right
not every time you mean not any time I
haven't actually made a target yet okay
okay well can I have a do-over I really
didn't do good this time eh all right
may you show me what you can do May if
you're so special
oh why is this happening to me
all right May you got this I have a
tiger sorry I'm drooling okay to be so
happy about it also where the [__] do we
live what kind of penthouse amazing
apartment do you have okay huh Oh May
can you not gloat I have a severe
disability in that I have no arms I have
to control these puppets with my mind
I'm a oh wow man you suck damn
watch your mouth may man I thought whoa
okay may sorry I wonder do you want to
appeal I don't even know what I don't
make listen to me you little [__] if you
think I'm gonna stand for this May yeah
ain't gonna happen I know it's an boo
I know it's empty in that head of yours
huh oh you're good at dot oh you're good
at darts huh well it's not cuz we're
gonna play again and I'm going to show
you all right give you one more chance
oh I don't even need one more chance I
need this many more chances okay
beat me three times to unlock the next I
gotta beat this I can't even beat it
once let's lean forward is this
cheating is this cheating damn why are
you so lucky you know I don't know man I
I just don't know me oh my god May I'm
pretty good I'm real good May May I'm
pretty good May what do you think of
that well I [__] you oh now it's your
turn to suck get ready to be glad good
[__] talk mark great job okay
yeah why is this happening it's because
you're terrible may may you're the worst
you're the worst I've ever seen are you
short - and I'm tall obviously look out
- all I am compared to you okay
that's a bit excessive separation so
that's a bit excessive celebration for
something as mediocre as the two is what
I was gonna say but then it came out is
[__] out of my mouth so it kind of
lost the punch of the ability to insult
you I'm very clearly not oh oh I'll be
dead oh please
damned I'll be damned if I'm gonna lose
the new Wow
may you are literally the worst but I'll
beat you again
cool come on come on what okay one two
three not too bad
okay I just got to win three two more
times through my ultimate incredible
method of totally not cheating I got I
got one may it wasn't right I do look
pretty handsome man I am wearing my best
pants for this accentuates my bull okay
okay well that's not good but I bet it's
better than what you're gonna do a sucks
okay
shut the [__] up May Oh May sucks you
got a zero purse I like how this is
rigged against you that's pretty good in
my opinion it makes bad but bad okay
all right you can stop that it's really
not that big a deal may also I think
your shirts not gonna be able to handle
the structural integrity of your
bouncing you haven't done your best
where did I tell you about doing your
best May huh Oh what oh what oh what oh
what oh wow
[__] what did I hit okay may you're
going down again well you're going down
this time because I'm gonna stand way
back here to start out the next round
you ain't never gonna see this watch
this [__] okay I call this my pimp strut
oh [__] may you about to get booked okay
you look superb I know right
I am quite handsome [__] yeah you should
be scared little baby gonna cry watch
this [__] okay I know I don't know what
you said but I know all right what the
[__] have I ever told you that you suck
May okay you got one it's not that big a
deal may I know you're gonna lose so I'm
just taking a look at your apartment I'm
gonna own this I'm pretty sure we bet oh
man come on what are you get you got me
there you go what do you have nothing
not that exciting okay all right man
this date really sucks also I don't know
what kind of date you invite me over to
your apartment to play darts really
bizarre I mean I thought we could go out
see a movie or something but this is
okay too I guess
all right last shot you really got a
chance of this oh yeah
really good job man you're doing great
what no no that's so sad for you you
stand too close to the darts no I'm not
you are a liar listen you're a goddamn
liar and if you if you if you think nice
nice hair
nice nice if you think I'm gonna allow
you if you think I'm gonna allow you to
call me a cheer I ain't gonna stand for
it so no we're not gonna play again why
am I doing this because I wanted to win
really badly and I wanted to win at this
date which I am cuz I'm great
Oh God why are you oh [__] why does she
have a gun I don't why does she have a
gun oh oh we're already a couple nice vo
no clean who's clean okay this is
getting way too meta I don't even know
okay I well I didn't did I get any
vanish the game she recommended were
horrible I hope not this time well
that's a little rude it's okay this is
getting too meta I Oh fire missiles oh
man I'm not too sure about this may it's
getting I mean I'm playing a VR game in
a VR do I have to kill you
all right well what get ready to get
[__] me missiles away oh [__] alright
well what the [__] hey oh my god I don't
understand what's happening or why May
where did you go mei-mei Oh Oh Jaime why
do you get so much [__] and I get
nothing
okay Mays gone now oh [__] that's a
little scary May I think it's one of
those situations where if you die in the
game you die in real life and I don't
want to test that theory this is a
really impressive VR game inside this VR
game I guess oh hey may I get ready to
die
and oh I'm so sorry may you suck I win
you suck
I'm the best I don't really feel good
about it but I feel like I won oh you
were ruthless when shooting yes I was
that's how you win listen here you
little [__] I don't care if you're
digital or not I I don't care I don't
want to do this I don't want to talk to
you like this but you are giving me a
lot of sass I know that heads yeah I
know that heads empty
hey why don't these work this VR okay
there we go sorry
hmm that doesn't seem right
hmm well that's not normal
all right listen make all right listen
man you need to take this seriously
it was a very serious game that you need
to take seriously you don't take it
seriously you could lose and die
probably I bet I could do this on hard
nobody make any jokes about that all
right man get ready to get shot like
crazy Oh
scary I think that would be instant
death but why does make it all the
cheesy [__] I don't care if it's
supposed to make it more fair [__]
oh man tricking me out there huh nope
may you're going down man I'm just gonna
go straight for you oh [__] hey I'm the
best I know it don't even try to pretend
like you don't know it you're not
reconciled no you lose and you stay lost
this date sucks alright I guess this is
all been leading up to this moment this
moment this sweet moment in my life when
I'm gonna feel love for better
experience please take a seat I think we
know where this is going this is what
virtual reality has been leading up to
all my life hang on I got a angle the
camera down for this bad boy here I'll
just sit back and relax all right
sitting properly and ready oh I am hang
on wait hang on I am ready and I am
sitting properly let's do this you're
stuffed not yet we've barely gotten
started oh oh I don't want black beans
well neither do I I think you won't eat
it what kind of spoiled [__] are you
well I don't want your portion what a
spoiled little [__]
I don't care how small your shirt is
you're gonna eat these black beans what
honey what it's like The Rock Paper
Scissors chops for beating what what's
the big deal about these black beans
what's wrong with other scissors oh boy
okay all right
the game is tied indeed it is paper Oh
No
buh oh good [__] you ready to eat some
black beans oh [__] this is what my life
has been waiting for my whole life okay
[Music]
nope okay that immediately that one got
away from me
good job okay wait wait wait well that's
good [__] you [__] you [__] you and [__]
this goddamn dinner
I deserve to give you a black bean that
[__] sorry about your boob I can't throw
very hard he's telling me playing darts
[__] [__] [__] give me your
chopsticks cuz you suck can you want
cherry flower you got um you got a you
got a plate in your boob you all right
you're clogged up there I needed to help
clear you out a little bit all right
there you go well that was weird
you are I hope you are a fully grown
adult that is able to make your own
decisions and not complain about these
black beans at least food Hey wow you
suck hey hey oh there you go shove it in
there okay wow I'm really excited about
this do we have to play good why do we
have to do this dude I know oh look at
that you suck I don't know why maybe
it's programmed to make you lose and
then shove it right up your nose and
that's good job ey whoa oh wow you do
suck you're really bad at this
that's not right I'm not right about
that
can I eat it all right whatever there
you go
they're just actually turds - I love
that beans are finally finished why was
that such a concern of yours why were
you so why that's okay hi let's play
something different okay forehead
flicking what the [__] is a forehead
flicking can you not flick your fingers
on my forehead what the [__] were you
about to hit me why do I keep having to
play rock paper scissors I don't know I
don't understand what the forehead flick
game is hi
excuse you look I don't lose anything
not even forehead flick I hope this
laser pointer blinds you got a chord you
know chords and oh my god I got chords
in the wedge oh my god I got chords in
the way please cover your cleavage you
yeah you no no don't please aah aah
oh my god I think you put out a piece of
my neck that was unpleasant at best okay
I win please do not no no no no no okay
all right well narrowly avoided death
again yes sure I guess I have to do this
nine times I'm not 100% sure why but I
have to go whoop oh don't don't please
No okay thank you for that okay well I
suck please don't no oh it goes into my
brain blue buff lab a Boop
there we go got ya all right listen
listen yep sorry hey Baba hope sorry
no I oh okay sorry yeah
[__] hell steal your goddamn black
beans
yeah probably Chippewa whoo I got you
all right listen don't you think I have
a girlfriend you're gonna do scissors
someday you're gonna do [__] scissors
someday or you're gonna feel the rock in
another place that you don't want can
you just do [__] citizen I don't want
yes yes yes ah all right one more
now you gonna do yes I want to play
again I don't even know what the reward
is for the end of this but it better be
worth it there you go you're done okay
nope don't like that thank you no idea
what I want to play again did I win what
did I win yeah yeah that's right
I don't want to play again what did I
win do I still need to sit down
hello Oh
[Music]
I don't know what this is and I don't
know if I should still be seated for it
Oh nope did you see my letter
I don't know red envelope for the
reunion I don't know what reunion you're
talking about but you look lovely I
guess huh huh huh what are we talking
about I don't even know if I can listen
lady I don't even know if we're dating
help me find the red lung blue
listen I don't even know if we're dating
or what this is gonna get me what
reunion are we talking about are we
friends are we high school roommates
this one Oh God don't mind as I wreck
your entire apartment I've gotta find it
I've gotta find the red envelope it's
got to be in here somewhere
don't worry mate I've got this nope not
in there nope not in there don't worry
May I'm gonna find it oh we can't escape
for me I'm just a goddamn expert at all
this what the [__] is red envelope why
do you have so many red books this is
[__] you know oh that's what I found
a red envelope eh you're the best I
found it for you oh hey how's it going
you have to go oh no that's so sad
no wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa May whoa maybe you're just May we
barely yeah I don't want to do that okay
Oh mess
may I
[Music]
that's you said bye-bye and you said it
said cui oh [__]
you're leaving me to clean Oh bye bye
bye but boom no
Mei Mei Mei I'm lost without you Mei you
can't just leave me like this
what about the black beans what about
the rock-paper-scissors may I fell in
love I fell in love and now I'm sad and
alone now I have nobody
[Music]
may
yeah Missy yeah I guess that's good yeah
[Music]
I guess asked a life lesson you fall in
love and play rock scissors you've
course feed your significant others and
black beans watch it run
[Music]
if you have love in your heart you've
lost like I've just lost
thank you everybody so much for watching
you want to send more stuff like this
and buy stuff like this honking now my
heart broken and left on the floor
bleeding the bone thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I'll see
you bye-bye
[Music]